now coronavirus infections are surging
across
africa at least one million new cases
were recorded in the past month alone
world health organization says the speed
and the scale of african's third wave
is like nothing they'd ever seen before
outbreaks are spiking almost everywhere
as you can see on this map
by the end of last week new cases in
nigeria were up 45 percent on the
previous week
170 percent in botswana and
in chad there's a dramatic peak to 200
percent
the surge is being blamed on two main
factors the spread of the highly
transmissible
delta variant which has now been
detected in 21 of africa's 54 countries
and the slowest vaccine rollout globally
less than 2 percent of africans have
been fully vaccinated
that's because of a lack of supplies and
vaccine
skepticism among other things south
africa is
the worst hit country on the african
continent in absolute numbers with
around
67 000 confirmed deaths even though
the real numbers are likely to be much
higher
this is great progress for renee being
able to exercise again
i came in coughing coughing coughing
today i'm 100 better doctors came to
tell me that all my blood works are
excellent so i'm
responding well with the medication
renee niker was lucky to get a bed in
this emergency covit 19 center in
johannesburg
a charity organization set up this ward
because public and private clinics
are overwhelmed now they too are
struggling to cope
and the recent unrest in the country
could help the coronavirus spread even
more quickly
we will soon be facing a huge
risk of food insecurity
and medication in security
in a few weeks
our vaccination program has been
severely disrupted
just as it is gaining momentum
the vaccination rollout in south africa
has been slow all along
the riots have made the campaign even
more difficult with vaccination sites
and pharmacies destroyed and looted
food shortages are making it hard for
people to avoid crowds
if we have members of the public
flocking into the shops and malls to buy
food stuff
we are also risking the spread of covert
19
and it will go to uncontrollable
uncontrollable levels
with the delta variant that is currently
prevalent in our country
in the emergency ward health workers are
worried about the number
of hospitalizations
this wave is a lot more aggressive it's
easily
transmitted and patients are now
presenting
with more severe symptoms too fast
south africa has recorded more covet 19
deaths
than any other african country with only
about three percent of its population
fully inoculated
speeding up the vaccination rate is now
essential
for more i'm joined now by yap boom he's
a public health
specialist and the regional head of
epicenter that's the
re research arm of doctors without
borders he joins us
from yonde in cameroon thanks for being
with us
professor bill why is africa being hit
so hard by covet 19 right now
there are several reasons you've
mentioned need the
new variant the delta environment that
is spreading
we have countries like uganda south
africa where
more to 95 percent of the new case are
due to that value that is one
two also the distancing measure were
no longer applied by the community so at
this point of time it's quite
challenging
considering that the virus is spreading
faster and rich
the more at risk population those who
have mobility and also the elder and we
are even seeing some young people
who are actually in a very critical case
which is quite concerning actually
let's talk about vaccines for a moment
uh according to the who
the world health organization less than
two percent of
africa's 1.3 billion people are now
fully vaccinated
is that mainly because there aren't
enough vaccines to go around or
is lack of infrastructure and vaccine
skepticism playing a big role here
now i think it's important to to
highlight that
more than 80 percent of the dose has
been used in the country and those that
were
available so the challenge right now is
really the availability
of the doors even in cameroon where we
have intensified the vaccination most of
the doors have been used
you go to uganda south africa where you
should report and you have
place site where the vaccine are no
longer available but the population are
in need
so actually it's a real crisis who
actually challenge the issue of
solidarity there is a critical need for
those
now so what needs to happen in order to
address this vaccine gap how
will africans get vaccinated
there are two things that has to happen
in parallel the first thing first is to
make
those available in the continent as soon
as possible
two is to strengthen to accelerate the
local pollution of the vaccine
because we are in the third fourth wave
and we know that more wave will be
coming and the covert initiative is
challenged because
of what's happening in india so we
definitely have
need to have those available in the
continent for now
but also for the upcoming future uh just
briefly professor
what are the risks of not getting
africans vaccinated quickly along with
the rest of the world
i think we are all interdependent which
means that if
africa is not fully vaccinated will have
an increased number of deaths
40 percent of increased in the last week
which will continue and that's a real
crisis
and secondly we'll have the emergence of
new variant
and those environment will keep on going
all around the world and even all those
countries
who have already been vaccinated for all
the population we don't know whether
they will resist those new variants so
we are all together and it's important
to remember
that we are not safe until everyone is
safe
professor thank you very much for
talking with us that was professor yap
boom speaking to us from yound cameroon
thank you
you